we turn now to houston where a man is in
custody after allegedly shooting three
police officers our houston affiliate
k-h-o-u reports that 31-year-old roland
caballero was arrested yesterday after a
lengthy standoff with police fortunately
all three officers are expected to
survive but as our jeff begez shows us
it's just the latest incident in what
was a deadly 2021 and already a violent
start to the new year for police
nationwide
[Applause]
this vehicle led police on a chase
through neighborhoods in central houston
yesterday its driver fled from a home
after officers responded to a
disturbance call once the car crashed
police say the driver opened fire on
officers
three of them were shot
cell phone video from the opposite angle
shows the suspect running away from the
scene with what appears to be an
automatic weapon in hand as officers
chased after him on foot police say he
then hijacked another car and fled that
vehicle's driver was not hurt police
eventually tracked the suspect to a home
where officers again took fire during a
prolonged standoff
the suspect surrendered after several
hours police say he had a gunshot wound
to the neck these violent individuals
i'm damn tired of it across the country
since the start of the new year there
have been numerous instances of police
being targeted and killed
also in the houston area a corporal was
shot dead during a traffic stop
in new york city yesterday a wake was
held for 22 year old officer jason
rivera after he and his partner were
killed responding to a domestic
disturbance call last friday president
biden plans to visit new york next week
where he will meet with the mayor and
discuss the white house's efforts to
combat gun crime including funding for
cities and states to hire more officers
and a federal crackdown on illegal gun
trafficking for cbs warnings i'm jeff
begayes